zach is in Connecticut hey Zach welcome
to the Dave Ramsey show hey thanks for
taking my fall
sure what's up no I have my question is
I'm trying to figure out what to do
about our house when my wife and I got
married a few years ago we need bought a
house close to my job and it's a
multi-family we rent out the upstairs
living the downstairs and it's a single
bedroom well now we have two kids both
under the age of two with a yard that's
less than the square footage of the
house and it's getting cranked really
fast so we're trying to figure out if we
should keep the house and buy another
one
sell it and just buy a single-family
home we have some friends that own real
estate and stuff and they all say don't
worry about it just hang on to it don't
they've all regretted selling property
you know so but whatever and then there
they said just buy a single-family house
take on two mortgages which I don't
really like that idea and I think you
wouldn't either but I just wanted to get
your advice on that know what to do
I love investing in real estate but I do
it with cash right and I would not keep
a rental property that has debt on it or
that causes you to have debt by the fact
that you kept it and so my guess is that
this house is not paid for and that you
don't have enough money in the bank to
pay cash for the next house right which
means you're right now cuz we okay yeah
you need to sell this your friends are
wrong and and then just do something
like the sell of this we we buy the new
house contingent on the sale this one
yeah yeah and get that one sold get rid
of it and you know make your move a
standard move you know we may people
always do it but don't become a landlord
by default meaning that you just the
only way you became a landlords I
already owned it and I just kept it
that's generally not a good plan I mean
generally you want to pick out the
particular property that's going to give
you a good return on investment and
that's the property I want to buy as my
investment property and in my case I'm
always going to tell you to pay cash for
that it's a little slower to build it
that way but you don't have to do it
twice
I had to do it twice because I had a
four million dollars worth of real
estate with three million dollars with a
debt on it in my 20s and I lost it all
because I was stupid and I had too much
debt and there's lots of friends of mine
sitting around going man you know
property battery no gravity yeah we're
not even rental property
well the freaking stuff owns you if you
do it wrong it's that are you own a net
and your little dream turns into a big
nightmare and that's what happened to me
so I took 30 years of the side of that
and start buying real estate with cash
and took a while to build buy the first
one took a little while to buy the
second one but you get 2 or 3 of these
paid for they start making money you can
buy another one then you can buy another
one then you can buy another one you got
plenty of time but get into your
property get into your home and get it
paid for that's your first step and get
your family taken care of that's your
first step rental properties way on your
back burner right now